[Music]
not too long ago the three seas marvel
series daredevil moved from netflix to
disney plus the series was so well
received by netflix that over the years
iron fist luke cage jessica jones and
the punisher were added to the catalog
and of course the ensemble series the
defenders which brings together all the
aforementioned superheroes eventually a
clause in the contract between netflix
and marvel came into effect which
prevent the continuation of the series
characters at disney for a period of
exactly two years after its termination
at netflix so it's all the more
gratifying that disney has finally
ordered its own series for daredevil
from the company's own streaming
platform disney plus many details have
not been revealed so far but one thing
is pretty much certain charlie cox will
return as the main character matt
murdock aka daredevil this can be
assumed at the latest since the brief
appearance and spider-man the way home
where the lawyer shows up in an opening
scene with vincent d'onofrio's kingpin
there is also another familiar face he
already made an appearance in the
hawkeye series it does looks like the
comic of some of the former cast members
is also imminent though there are no
further concrete indications of this yet
we can also only make guesses as to the
concept of this series because it is
still subject to speculation whether the
new disney plus series will function
completely as a reboot or even
seamlessly pick up where the predecessor
left off either way we are excited about
the new series in view of disney's
packed schedule we don't expect this
series to be released soon however
the first trailer for the upcoming mcu
series she-hulk attorney-in-law was
recently released apart from an
appearance by mark ruffalo as bruce
banner both fans and critics were not
really impressed by the clips shown the
focus is on the criticism of the poorly
done special effects which were probably
not quite convincing to anyone in
addition to many shrek comparisons some
fans also disliked the super aaron's
looks as many had hoped for a more
muscular or fearsome portrayal as cgi
artist sean rookcroft confirmed she was
initially designed to be more muscular
but was then given her current much
slimmer form however this could not be
that big of a deal since it keeps the
character very close to the comic books
which is definitely not the case with
other disney films like the little
mermaid as has often been the subject of
criticism in the past but not only the
fans are critical of the new she-hulk
series an insider also claims to have
heard nothing good as matthew baloney
reported to puck. news she-hulk is
destined to be a big flop baloney
already referred to various sources
behind the scenes last march who are not
too confident about the release of the
series in addition to teddy anna
misslania she-hulk and mark ruffalo's
hulk the cast also includes tim roth as
the villain abomination jamila jamil as
titania and benedict wrong as well wong
behind the scenes kat koiro and anuvalia
both directed while jessica gao wrote
the script so far the mcu project has
unfortunately not been well received and
it remains to be seen whether at least
the visual flaws will be corrected by
the time this series premieres on disney
plus on august 17 2022
recently after a long wait the second
trailer for thor love and thunder was
finally released in it we can at last
take a look at the big highlight of the
mcu blockbuster we are talking about
thor's exposed butt and the loki easter
egg but about christian balin is already
terrifying an equally promising role as
gore the butcher for another look at
gore check out the new poster that was
released this past tuesday which also
features other important characters by
the way in an interview with total film
director taika waititi also talked about
the fourth thor movie there he was asked
how closely thor love and thunder will
be based on the original comic the
mighty thor he stated that especially
jane foster's storyline will be very
close to the original after all this is
one of the most influential plot lines
of the film as part of the interview
there was also an exclusive new image
that shows natalie portman as mighty
thor and chris hemsworth as
four given all the new footage and news
we are now even more excited and looking
forward to the release this summer on
july 8th 2022
with the production of the last of a
series hbo has not chosen a simple
series adaption the part 2 video game
series by uncharted developer naughty
doc is still one of the major hits of
the past playstation generation until
now without an official announcement it
was widely assumed that the series would
be released in the course of the coming
year and as it recently turned out that
was not a wrong prediction at all
this emerged from an interview with
director academia balagoff with
comicbook.com where he provided an
approximate time frame according to him
a release could be possible in early
2023 already which luckily means less
than a year's wait the series is largely
based on the events of the two sony
exclusive video games there you play the
two main characters joel and ellie who
have to survive as an unlikely team in a
world full of infected creatures called
runners
the goal is to find an antidote for the
plague caused by fungi in addition to
fighting against the many human enemies
that are no less dangerous so far the
cast for the roles is very promising the
mandalorian star pedro pascal plays the
smuggler joe and the young ally is
played by game of thrones actress bella
ramsay in additional roles we will see
merle dandridge as fireflies leader
marlene nico parker as joel's daughter
sarah nick offerman as loner bill anna
torf as fellow smart letters and storm
reed as ali's friend riley we are
looking forward to the realization of
the last of us and await further news on
the hbo series
new actors are constantly joining the
cast of fast and furious 10 or fast axe
for short whether it's big roads like
jason momoa's or just minor ones one of
these more minor roles was recently
given to a true hollywood icon and
that's rita moreno the 90 year old west
side story actress was one of the few
performers to win every major film award
in the industry during her 70 year
career in other words oscar grammy amy
tony award and golden globe in fact only
16 people have managed to do that in
film history so that's an extremely
impressive lifetime achievement in a
cute video on instagram vin diesel
revealed the casting of moreno who will
play dumb dorado's grandmother in the
film in addition to moreno the return of
a well-known fast and furious star has
also been confirmed the talk is of scott
eastwood who is not only the son of
clint eastwood in fast and furious he
also played the role of little nobody it
is still unclear on who sadly nobody
will be and whether kurt russell will
also return as mr nobody the shooting of
fast axe under the new director luis
letriere is well underway and we are
hoping for more news about the already
giant movie which is scheduled to hit
theaters on may 19 2023
the ocean series is still one of the
best highest movies of all time but did
you know that the film series did not
start with george clooney brad pitt and
matt damon in 2001 but back in the 60s
at that time the movie had an equally
famous cast the so-called rat pack
played the three leading roles namely
none other than frank sinatra dean
martin and sammy davis jr now a new
ocean's 11 was announced a couple of
days ago and it's supposed to return to
the origins of the movie series as
stated by the hollywood reporter the
film is set in the 1960s somewhere in
europe allegedly the movie is not
related to the previous parts and could
therefore be sort of a remake the main
role has already been cast margot roby
is said to act not only as the main
character but also as a producer further
details are still scarce but it seems
likely that the original 1960 film and
the ocean's 11 remake are somehow
connected in las vegas danny ocean and
his team go on a foray and in europe
margot robbie's character and her
colleagues however this has not been
confirmed yet which is why we can only
make assumptions about it at this point
in time in charge of directing his
austin powers director jay roach this
script will be written by newcomer
carrie sullivan shooting of the warner
brothers film is scheduled to start at
the beginning of next year which is why
release before 2024 is considered
unlikely so far it is not known when the
new garfield movie starring chris pratt
will be released the plot of the
upcoming animated movie is also still
unknown but instead the next top class
addition to the cast has already been
announced we are referring to hollywood
legend samuel l jackson who is to take
on the role of garfield's father vic
this role was created specifically for
the new film but no further details have
been revealed by those responsible yet
chicken little director mark dindle will
be in charge of directing the movie
which will be adapted from a screenplay
by david reynolds among other projects
reynolds has previously worked on
disney's tarzan and finding nemo and is
by no means new to the animated film
business
we will keep you posted as soon as we
know more about the release date or some
initial plot information
this week we can offer you many brand
new trailers on our channel including
thor love and thunder and mission
impossible 7. in addition you can look
forward to a new original for shazam
fury of the gods there you will learn
everything you need to know about the
much anticipated dc movie
[Music]
foreign